i'm janis dean i'm brett baer i'm martha
mccallum and this
is the fox news rundown
friday july 30th 2021 i'm lisa brady
washington is fighting over
infrastructure covet and the events of
january 6th
but will any of it affect the midterm
elections governing in the in a 50-50
majority in the senate the three-vote
majority in the house is really
difficult and i
i have yet they are doing a great job of
it so far so i i like our chances in
2022.
i'm chris foster star gymnast simone
biles has been the talk of the summer
olympics for not competing and focusing
on her mental health
the sport of gymnastics is 90 mental it
really is these young girls have
dedicated hours and hours years and
years their whole childhood
their muscles have memory their bodies
already know how to do the skill
but if your mind is working in fighting
against you you're not going to be able
to do anything
we speak with three-time olympic
medal-winning gymnast dominique dodds
and i'm greg jarrett i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
infrastructure week is a long-running
joke in washington because of so many
stalled efforts over the years
but a trillion dollar bipartisan package
cleared its first hurdle in the senate
wednesday night
hours after a deal on major sticking
points we were able to
by reaching this agreement able to
narrow the focus to physical
infrastructure
to necessities of modernizing our
transportation system
extending broadband to every community
west virginia republican senator shelly
moore capito helped lead talks with the
white house which agreed to a framework
weeks ago but senate majority leader
chuck schumer still has a two-track
plan my goal remains to pass both a the
bipartisan infrastructure bill
and a budget resolution during this work
period
both he's pushing the president's larger
human infrastructure plan a more than 3
trillion
effort to address many other issues from
child care to climate change and
using the budget reconciliation process
which means not needing any republican
support
but it would need all 50 senate
democrats and some progressive democrats
in the house
say they won't pass one bill without the
other so the bipartisan senate deal has
a long way to go
for now though it's moving i think they
did i mean actually really good work
this thing has been dead
like 25 different times and they did it
north dakota republican congressman
kelly armstrong but i've been saying
this at home and to anybody out in d.c
we haven't even seen you know on tuesday
the
house democrat majority went down to
three votes and we haven't even seen
four democratic members of the house
conference flex their muscles yet
it takes four people to make sure they
don't have enough votes on their side
and i think the dynamics change a lot on
our side on the republican
side if these are paired together and
instead of
a reasonable hard infrastructure bill
that is has bipartisan support if it's
tapped with three and a half trillion
and it's a and it's a two for one i
think the dynamics just get a little
different on the house side for
republicans
yeah i mean how concerned are you about
democrats maybe using reconciliation and
passing trillions in spending on their
own
or could that end up being a good thing
for republicans
if the american people don't like that
move
well i think i mean as somebody who's
been talking about the debt since even
before i got into congress and
actually i mean even over the last two
years
i think politically um this is going to
mean people care about inflation they
care about the rising cost of everything
right now and so yeah i think from a
political standpoint
this is listen governing in the in a 50
50 majority in the senate and a
three-vote majority in the house is
really difficult and i
i have yet to they aren't doing a great
job of it so far so i like our chances
in 2020 too
congressman armstrong is one of several
republicans caught up in a partisan feud
over the new select committee
investigating the capital riot which
held its first hearing this week
emotional testimony from four
law enforcement officers i was grabbed
beaten
tased all while being called a traitor
to my country
i was at risk of being stripped of and
killed with my own firearm
as i heard chance of killing with his
own gun
metropolitan police officer michael
fanon and the others describing bloody
battles with people who appeared to be
prepared for exactly that
some taunting black officers with racial
slurs
including capitol police private first
class harry dunn
i told them to just leave the capitol
and in response they yelled
no man this is our house president trump
invited us here
but house minority leader kevin mccarthy
has accused house speaker nancy pelosi
of abusing her power
essentially controlling the narrative
and he withdrew all of his proposed
committee members
including armstrong after pelosi
rejected two of the others
congressman jim banks and jim jordan
who's called the probe impeachment 3.0
i wondered whether congressman armstrong
would have wanted to stay
on the committee i would have rather all
five of us were allowed to stay on that
committee uh
i mean i've been pretty adamant i'm not
a big fan
of sitting things out i always say
there's not
you mean if they have 20 hearings
there's not 20 different ways to take
your ball and go home
um and it's important to be a part of
those conversations but i think
what leader mccarthy did was absolutely
appropriate listen as the minority party
in a very closely divided house we
essentially represent half of the
american people
and when you allow speaker pelosi to
populate minority
members of a committee it's not just
about being unfair to the minority
members of congress it's being
unfair to all of their constituents and
all of the voters that might have a
different viewpoint from speaker pelosi
so i think it's really important
i think i i was a criminal defense
attorney for 10 years
and the hardest cases are when your
process and your procedures have to work
the best
i've said this several times every time
speaker pelosi calls something
unprecedented
what it really means is she galvanizes
more power
in her office and that's not good for
the institution that's not good for the
country and it's not good for my
constituents in north dakota
leader mccarthy has called that process
a sham
accusing the speaker of just playing
politics the two republicans who
are still on the committee appointed by
pelosi
say it's a search for the truth what
would you say to them
well after i watch the whole hearing and
i will say this and this is
this is a deficiency of a lot of
congressional hearings but i think it's
even more
exasperated on this one very early on in
the testimony
um officer dunn said that they were
woefully unprepared that day
the hearing went on for another two and
a half hours and not a single member
republican or democrat
followed up on that question that is a
very important question
if you want to make sure something like
this never happens again
you want to make sure that everybody
works here covers this place in the
press
visits here is safe moving now into the
future and more importantly we have to
do that in a way that keeps the capital
open and available to the to the public
because that's one of the things that
makes this country great and it is still
one of the things even in this divided
time that makes this
this city great i guess as the committee
goes on with
future hearings we'll see what what kind
of questions they do go on to ask
um but congresswoman liz chaney uh at
the start of the hearing accused fellow
republicans of trying to whitewash what
happened that day as she put it defend
the indefensible
what about the argument that not being
clear enough
perhaps about what led to the attack
could continue to undermine
democracy well i and i think republicans
have said that right we
we said this evidence should take us
wherever it goes but chairman thompson
said
in one in one statement he said
absolutely everything's on the table
and then in another statement he said
except the speaker's office which is i
mean the capitol police board is made up
sergeant-at-arms and all of those
different people so i i firmly believe
they should take the evidence wherever
they're taking it but i didn't i didn't
get a lot of confidence from that in the
first hearing
and with regards to whitewashing what
happened on january 6th
uh i've been very vocal about that i've
criticized people on the
my side of the aisle about those things
i was in the capitol i was in the
chamber when this happened
um and i i don't think that's
appropriate and again i don't care what
what side of the aisle you're on that it
was a bad day it was a terrible day it
was a dangerous day
and the law enforcement officers on the
ground um
were heroic they were battling against a
riot they were battling without being
fully prepared and i think we should
always remember that
one thing the republican party has been
pretty united about
is accusing big tech of censorship and i
know there's work underway on bills
to reform section 230 for instance which
is what shields those companies from
liability
i know you're sponsoring one piece of
that related to
product liability what would that do so
um yeah and ranking member jordan and
ranking member kathy mcmorris rogers
have come out with a bill on 2 30. part
of that bill is 230 product liability
reform
essentially uh i think one of the things
that happens a lot in dc
i mean we've i've been through two
different committees and two different
hearings with big tech
and there's bipartisan anger at big tech
it's just not always about the same
thing
and i think a lot of times those tech
companies play on our partisan divisions
to keep
to keep nothing from really happening
and 230 is a perfect example i think
there are democrats that would rather
censor more speech on
online and republicans often obviously
disagree with that
but product liability should be a
nonpartisan issue i'll use a company
like amazon for example
you get 230 product liability if you're
a middleman in the transaction if
somebody sells somebody else a widget
and that widget is defective and hurts
somebody
uh you you you go after the manufacturer
not the middleman
the problem is is this isn't amazon is
not a middleman in these transactions
they're completely interwoven into the
entire supply chain
as to how e-commerce and online commerce
works
and they shouldn't be afforded those
protections anymore because they truly
do
significantly more and i think everybody
knows that
as far as online commerce goes so one of
these one of the reasons i'm excited
about it is i think we should be able to
garner some bipartisan support for it
and there's no silver bullet in dealing
with big tech i mean
first of all we have to define
oftentimes what big tech
is and that could be different if you're
talking about data privacy or censorship
versus e-commerce but i think this is a
this is this is a good bill it's good
reform
it's it it will hold people accountable
in the liability stage the way they
should be without putting
overly undue burdens on small small
businesses that are trying to provide
commerce in the new digital age it's
certainly not hard to imagine
some some pushback if and when that
passes from
some some of the bigger companies
involved
i wanted to ask you about this new covet
surge around the country
that has reignited the debate about
mandates and personal freedoms and
now vaccine mandates are starting to
spread in public health systems
state and federal employees do you think
companies and governments
are going too far uh yeah i do and i
think it's not going to solve the
problems they're trying to solve
um it's it's very
it's very unfortunate that these types
of things have become a
political issue determining whether or
not you're going to get a vaccine
is a medical personal issue they
shouldn't listen to me
they shouldn't listen to anybody else
they should go speak with their doctor
our a doctor and get that information
but not only do i not
support mandates from a legal point of
view i think from a practical point of
view you're just going to continue to
drive a wedge for the people
who are trying to i mean get vaccinated
or
to potentially think about taking the
vaccine anyway but
they don't work we're a very individual
society
uh unfortunately our political divisions
run pretty deep right now and i think
from a legal standpoint they're a
terrible idea and i think from a
practical standpoint they're a terrible
idea
certainly some of the numbers right now
are pretty scary though i mean is there
anything else you think
that would be more effective in trying
to control the spread
you know i always i don't always like to
criticize without giving a positive
solution but i think the mass confusion
coming out of cdc is not helping
anything
um it seems like these decisions are
being made i mean we're finding out
right now that
the study that they're basing on the new
mass guidelines is from india it hasn't
been peer-reviewed
nobody is honest about why they change
rules and
the american people see that the
american people are skeptical about that
so sometimes i think less is more uh
have i talked to people deal with those
things i mean i'm i'll tell you i tell
you the same thing i tell everybody
if you haven't been vaccinated yet you
should go
talk to your doctor listen to them i i
mean i have
two wonderful children and if i trusted
those people to deliver my children i'm
going to trust them with my medical
advice because i'm not an expert
and i really do trust those people to
give me the best advice and then make
the decision what's best for you and
your family
well north dakota republican congressman
kelly armstrong
we're very thankful for your time today
thanks for having
me
[Music]
this is greg jarrett with your fox news
commentary coming up
team usa's cenisa lee 18 years old from
minnesota wins the women's all-around
gymnastics olympic gold medal at the
games in japan
not competing was four-time olympic gold
medalist simone biles
she dropped out of team competition last
week in the overall individual meet
yesterday citing a need to focus on her
mental health
she's had a lot of support from her
teammates other athletes fans and
just people sympathetic to what she's
going through a lot of other people
though
are calling her weak selfish and they're
accusing her of giving up on her team
and the country she represents
you know anyone that calls simone
selfish or weak they clearly don't know
how tough this young girl is and what
she's persevered and will continue to
persevere like
dominique dawes was a member of the us
gymnastics team for 10 years winning a
gold medal in 1996 and the bronze in
1992 and 2000.
you know they haven't walked a day in
her shoes i personally have gone through
similar experiences but again
i'm not simone bios i don't know what's
going on in her head i don't know what's
going on in her heart
but as a three-time olympian a woman of
color someone said to myself i am so
thrilled that she listens to her inner
voice that is courageous and that is
it takes a great deal of humility to do
what she did she did not sacrifice
her whole childhood to get to her second
olympic game
only to choose to bow out no she clearly
wasn't enough pain mentally
and was very careful that she could
injure herself physically and she did
what was right for simone
yeah i mean that disappointing vault
before she walked off it looked to me
like she could have been seriously hurt
if she hadn't been as talented
enough to recover to the extent that she
did
uh yes definitely i mean they talk about
these twisties or something that
what didn't necessarily have a name when
i was in the sport of gymnastics where
people
get lost completely in the air and
i used to go through those mental blocks
a lot throughout my career
and it's a very scary time it's very
scary mentally and it's also very scary
physically because
as you saw she could injure herself
greatly
the level of difficulties that she does
in her skills if she's just off a little
bit
she could truly break a limb even and
she knows that and she's 24 so she's
pretty wise for her age
and she knows that the best thing for
her to do is to bow out for
for a moment yeah i mean i've never
heard of the twisties until a few days
ago i guess maybe you hadn't either
until
i guess didn't have a name like you said
i don't know if that's exactly what
she's going through but
um i mean there's a similar thing in
golf and baseball called the yips
where you can't make a putt or you can't
make a short throw even if you're
you know a great player they're a mental
aspect to sports where your head just
isn't right
yep you just will maybe it's
overthinking things i remember my coach
used to always say
analysis paralysis and i was a thinker i
was a very emotional gymnast it was a
lot on me it was too much many times on
me
and if i was going through a tough time
in my life where my parents were going
through a pretty bad divorce or
just my regular home life it was a lot
of stress on me and then in the
gymnastics gym
coupling that with that pressure uh that
level of commitment it started to break
me a little bit mentally i remember
being back in the day
a huge yankee fan back in the day with
derek jeter's days
and i remember there was a third baseman
that had a very hard time throwing it to
first base
and everyone was like what is going on
until you've walked a day in that
individual shoes and then
at that high level of excellence would
you
truly understand it but he had trouble
doing the most basic things that are
taught in little league and that many
times
is from an over analysis of things
yeah i mean you're not a robot i mean i
guess you're sort of trained to pee
um is there any mental training or is it
just
suck it up back in the day in the sport
of gymnastics it was very much the suck
it up mentality it was you were doing
this for your country you were doing
this because you were told that you're
doing this we were very much viewed in
gymnastics as little robots and you can
even see the looks on our faces at the
1992 olympic games in barcelona spain
when i was 15 years old or even in 1996
the level of intensity and this very
iconic moment from the 1996 olympic
games we carry strugg went for the final
vault
her coach is on the sideline saying you
can do it it was very much you will do
it
you don't have a choice she didn't have
a choice and she sacrificed herself her
own mental health as well as her
physical health
to go and do it for her country for the
federation for her coaches for her
family
all these people that were relying on
her for her team even
and she ended up making that vault many
people saw that as a heroic moment
however it should have really shined the
light
on the culture in the sport of
gymnastics you don't have control
as an athlete you are told what to do
when to do it and you will sacrifice
things at all costs
these young gymnasts today simone biles
leading the way
recognize that their inner voice is
speaking they hear their inner voice and
they're listening to it because she
realizes
there's more to life than just
gymnastics she has a life after this and
many more years hopefully to go
where she could be a mother a
businesswoman you name it
a philanthropist and she knows that this
is just a chapter in her life
and why risk her mental health or her
physical health for this
yeah as far as the team goes you can
make the case
that she improved the team's standings
that maybe they wouldn't have won that
silver if she had stuck it out and then
continued to perform worse even if she
didn't hurt herself
that's what she was saying that she was
even concerned about jeopardizing the
team getting on the podium if she's
going through these
twisties the many times she's twisting
throughout the rest of the competition
she does a double double off bars that's
twisting she does a double double off
beam that's twisting
she has multiple tumbling passes with
twists in it and if she's
mentally off there could have been a
result of not only an injury but
multiple multiple falls yeah she put out
the statement saying that the love and
support she's been getting has just made
her realize even more that she's
more than her trophy case or more than
just gymnastics i mean
it must be hard though to think of
yourself as anything but a gymnast if
that's
been your life since you were a little
girl yeah that that is your life that
was my life when i was six to
probably 30 something years old that i
realized i was more than just a gymnast
i retired when i was 24
and ran into a period of being depressed
and lost and going through a dark period
because
i was no longer wearing my leotard i was
no longer hearing the crowd cheer i was
no longer
dominique the gymnast the active
olympian and i really never thought of
what's next for my life you're not
prepared for that exit
of an environment that has controlled
you so much and i love the fact that
she's now recognizing
it's not just about her gold medals
she's an amazing person she's got an
amazing heart and she's got an amazing
soul
and that's what's going to help her
continue to leave a lasting legacy
um there's still a lot of criticism of
usa gymnastics you talked about the
toxicity when you were
um competing and that's the stereotype
it's not even women's gymnastics
i mean we're talking about girls in most
cases here and
overbearing coaches and parents maybe
abusive not just sexual abuse like
team doctor larry nassar's stuff but i
mean screaming emotional abuse maybe
stuff with diets is that as prevalent
as ever or is it hopefully less so well
i started my own gymnastics academy a
year ago it's called the dominique dawes
gymnastics and ninja academy
really to give young people a healthier
option
my academy is all about creating a
compassionate environment a healthy
environment an empowering environment
really about developing the whole child
not just trying to build
and make and mold champions on the floor
but more importantly happy healthy kids
in life
we still need to shine the light on this
full
journey of what many athletes go through
in the sport of gymnastics i was the
executive producer of a docu series
called golden and it was also executive
produced by
lebron james and maverick carter and
what i love about
this docu-series where we follow five
olympic hopefuls
we need to leave being one of them we
see the full level of sacrifice the
commitment
the frustration the fear the anxiety and
the toll that it takes
to get a shot at an olympic game the
sort of gymnastics
really does force you as a young girl to
give up your childhood
and i don't think it needs to be the way
i think we can build
champions in life and not make them so
one-dimensional
yeah one more question about simone
bile's mental stuff i mean is it is it
fair
to compare it with a with a physical
injury i mean yeah maybe you can compete
with a sprain
say and maybe somebody tries to force
you but you probably won't be as good
and you might hurt yourself
like we said um to compare
what her mental state is to a physical
injury
yeah i mean you know what i mean like if
you've got a sprain
let's say your coach could say no you're
getting out there and competing anyway i
don't care what's going on with your
knee
is it sort of the same thing where she
needs time to recover from whatever's
going on in her head
yeah i think it could be seen as similar
um
in fighting against you you're not going
to be able to do anything certainly not
or
are not going to be able to live up to
the pressure and you're not going to
be able to enjoy the experience that was
one thing simone said she's like we're
not having fun we should be having fun
none of my olympic games were fun it was
all a job it was all
hard work but i love the fact that they
want to make sure
that they're having fun and so the
mental aspect is a huge component of it
but you can compare it similar
to um an injury uh but again if you
don't have the mental part together
then it really won't matter much do you
think there are
or or have been really really talented
girls
who could have excelled in the sport but
just said nope this is not for me i'm
not putting up with this i do
and quit when they're 12. yes i
witnessed it i've witnessed it
throughout my career so many young girls
coming to
the gym that i was training at they
physically had
everything to excel in a sport
but mentally either the sport broke them
or their parents were wise enough that's
what's lacking today
their parents were wise enough to see
the long-term ill effect on their young
daughter
i saw some very talented girls step into
the sport
but they got out of it because those
long-term effects can be
can be damaging let me ask you one more
just watching as a viewer
these olympics in general it's just kind
of weird without the fans
um it's great watching the competition
but it's still it's it's
it's off is it do you think it's do you
think it's affecting the athletes not
just gymnasts necessarily but
everybody is it creepy to be out there
the quiet
it's not normal and it doesn't feel like
an olympic game
at all not only to the fans even though
this is the most watched olympic game
ever we are
gathering as fans and communities and
cheering on these athletes
the fact that there are not people there
cheering them on and adding to the
adrenaline rush
and the experience which many times
could be positive but it also adds
another layer of pressure
that component is missing obviously of
these olympic games and
again even one of the athletes i believe
it was simone biles was like that's
a factor that is not normal we're used
to having the fans there
for good or for bad like it's a
distraction they're accustomed to it so
it has to be uncomfortable
for these athletes but they are all
making us proud each and every day of
these games
well i can't think of anybody i would
have rather talked to about this today
dominique dawes
awesome dawson 1996 olympic gold
medalist with team usa a member of
several halls of fame
uh dominique thank you very much for
coming on oh well thank you so much i
appreciate it
fox news radio on demand on the fox news
app download the app and just click
listen when you swipe left you can
listen to your favorite fox news talk
shows live swipe right for the latest
fox news radio newscasts on demand
fox news radio and the fox news app
download it today
read and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
[Music]
an israeli woman who recently celebrated
her 50th birthday
decided that instead of getting gifts
she was going to give one a big one
edith harold siegel is a kindergarten
teacher from northern israel
and remembered the words of her
grandfather a holocaust survivor he had
told her
to live meaningfully so siegel contacted
a group that links organ donors
and recipients she had decided to give
someone one of her own
kidneys the move started a nine-month
process to transfer her kidney to
someone who needed one
the associated press reports that
someone turned out to be a
three-year-old palestinian boy from the
gaza strip
the situation was not without
controversy siegel's husband and the
oldest of her three sons did not agree
with the idea
and her father stopped speaking to her
the case of the gaza boy was complicated
to speed up the process his father who
was not a match for his son
was told by the hospital that if he were
to donate a kidney to an israeli
recipient
the boy would immediately go to the top
of the list
on the same day his son received a new
kidney the father donated one of his own
to a 25 year old israeli mother of two
siegel said her husband
understands better now as do her
children and on the eve of her surgery
her father called she told him her
kidney was going to a palestinian boy
for a moment there was silence and then
her father spoke
well he said he needs life also
tanya j powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
greg jarrett
what's on your mind mark twain once
mused that if you find yourself on the
side of the majority
it's time to pause and reflect well
there'll be no pause or reflection by
the house select committee
investigating the january 6 attack on
the u.s
capitol house speaker nancy pelosi won't
allow it
her narrative of what happened that
terrible day
is the only one permitted pelosi's
democrat party is the majority in the
house of representatives
albeit narrowly as speaker she rules
like a
tyrant she abides no dissent tolerates
no differing opinion
and is contemptuous of the truth only
her truth
is indulged any contrary evidence will
be suppressed or covered up
pelosi has no interest in the full story
of what happened on january 6th
she blames the great villain donald
trump for everything
and will countenance no other inquiry or
outcome
for pelosi it's not enough that the
rioters who committed crimes are being
prosecuted
nor that trump was impeached and
acquitted after he left office no
pelosi demands more under threat of
losing the majority in the midterm
elections next year
she engineered a purely bias committee
to do her bidding its conclusions are
preordained
likely written by pelosi herself a fair
and objective and truth-seeking
committee
would surely investigate why our
nation's capital was
significantly unprotected on january 6th
notwithstanding advance intelligence
warnings from
the fbi the department of homeland
security and the capitol police itself
that events could spiral out of control
with violence
as speaker of the house pelosi plays a
vital role in overseeing the capitol
police
she's partly responsible for maintaining
adequate security so it's both natural
and logical to ask
where was pelosi in all of this was she
aware of the alarming threat assessments
that painted a dire picture of violence
without
a substantial backup force from the d.c
metropolitan police or the national
guard
even worse did she ignore the threat
analysis
as leader of the house pelosi is not
blameless
the intelligence breakdowns and
dysfunctions within the capital security
system
point to an embarrassing failure of
leadership
and yet she has worked sedulously to
avoid
any inconvenient questions bearing on
her own
responsibility the prospect of being
called as a witness to answer for her
own conduct
must have given her night terrors the
inspector general all but
begged congress to investigate the
abysmal security failures
but pelosi won't stand for it perhaps
she fears her own incompetence or
malevolence
might be exposed for all to see
this would inevitably diminish her
underlying desire to exploit the tragic
events
as a political cudgel against
republicans in the 2022 elections
i suspect most americans see through
pelosi's charade
if they don't it's time for them to
pause
and reflect i'm greg jarrett
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
[Music]
jason in the house the jason chaffetz
podcast dive deeper than the headlines
in the party lines as i take on american
life
politics and entertainment subscribe now
on foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you
download podcasts
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes